On Thursday, January 22nd, I'll be hosting a conversation with Nate DeMayo of the Memory Palace at KQED in San Francisco. I could not be more of a fan of Nate in his writing, which is the best in all of podcasting. Please come see us and say hi. Again, that's the Memory Palace live at KQED in San Francisco on Thursday, January 22nd. We'll have a link to tickets and the show notes. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Happy 2026 beautiful nerds.
在1月22日星期四，我将在旧金山的KQED与《Memory Palace》的内特·德梅奥进行一场对谈。我简直不能更喜欢内特以及他的写作了，那是整个播客界最棒的。请来看我们并打个招呼。再次说明，那是1月22日星期四在旧金山KQED举办的《Memory Palace》现场活动。我们将在节目介绍中附上门票链接。这里是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马斯。祝各位聪明可爱的听众2026年快乐。
We are back and ready to kick off this new year with a fresh batch of mini stories. Usually, this is the place where I tease what's coming up on the episode. But in my attempt to rest control over minis and get them back to their fundamentals, once again, we are continuing with this new, hopefully improved process that I mentioned in the previous minis episode. We have three producers. They're gathered here in a Zoom to tell me stories that I have not heard before. I am again unprepared. So let's get started.
我们回来啦，准备好以全新的一批迷你故事开启新的一年。通常，这里是我预告本集内容的地方。但在我试图重新掌控迷你故事、让它们回归初衷的尝试中，我们再次延续了我在上一期迷你故事中提到过的那种全新的、希望有所改进的流程。我们有三位制作人。他们齐聚在一个Zoom会议里，向我讲述我从未听过的情节。我依然毫无准备。那么，我们开始吧。
First up is producer Jacob Medina Gleason. Happy New Year, Jacob. Thanks, Roman. Happy New Year's to you, too. So I want to start 2026 off by talking about sports. Okay. I'm not the biggest sports fan. I'm a women's basketball fan, and that's pretty much it.
首先登场的是制作人雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森。新年快乐，雅各布。谢谢你，罗曼。也祝你新年快乐。所以我想通过聊聊体育来开启2026年。好的。我算不上什么超级体育迷。我是女子篮球迷，差不多就这些。
But the Olympics are a few weeks away, and I have an Olympics-ish mini for you. I love an Olympics-ish mini, so hit me. Okay, so this is a story about a controversial swimsuit. It's called the Laser Racer. This is a racing suit that Speedo launched back in 2008. And the thing that made the laser racer so controversial is that Speedo really took advantage of the fact that World Aquatics was pretty lenient on what could be considered fabric.
但奥运会在几周后就要举行了，我为你准备了一个带有奥运色彩的迷你故事。我超爱带奥运色彩的迷你故事，快说来听听。好的，所以这是一个关于一件备受争议的泳衣的故事。它叫做“鲨鱼皮”（Laser Racer）。这是Speedo（速比涛）在2008年推出的一款竞速泳衣。让“鲨鱼皮”如此充满争议的原因在于，Speedo巧妙地利用了国际泳联对“什么可以被视为织物”管得相当宽松这一点。
Okay, what do you mean by that? So the suit was made of like your pretty typical swimsuit material, but in some areas like the abs in the lower back, the laser racer added a thin layer of polyurethane. And the addition of this rubbery material helps swimmers create less drag as they move through the water. Well, interesting. So I'm no physicist. But drag slows you down. And so if you want to get faster, you want less of it. Absolutely. Yeah. It's why swimmers wear swim caps and why they're always freshly shaved. Right. So any swimmer with a laser racer suit kind of immediately has this advantage in the pool.
好吧，你这话是什么意思？所以这件泳衣是由那种相当经典的泳衣材料制成的，但在某些区域，比如腹部和下背部，“鲨鱼皮”添加了一层薄薄的聚氨酯。而这种橡胶状材料的加入，有助于减少运动员在水中移动时的阻力。嗯，有意思。虽然我不是物理学家。但阻力会让你变慢。所以如果你想游得更快，你就会希望阻力越少越好。完全正确。是的。这就是为什么游泳运动员要戴泳帽，而且总是把体毛刮得精光。没错。因此，任何穿上“鲨鱼皮”泳衣的游泳运动员，在泳池里都会立刻拥有这种优势。
So what did world aquatics do about it? Because I imagine they want this stuff to be fair. Right. And that's the thing is. at first they didn't do anything. It was the IOC, the International Olympic Committee, that had to step in an issue ruling because the 2008 Summer Olympics were coming up. And as it stood, only swimmers with a sponsorship from Speedo were going to be able to wear the suit. So if you're wearing Mizzunos or whatever, you're immediately at a disadvantage. Yeah, because this thing had a lot of hype even before the Olympics. So the IOC ruled that the suit would only be allowed if it was made available to all competitors. So that's what happened. The suit was made available to everybody regardless of sponsorship.
那么国际泳联对此做了什么？因为我猜他们希望这些东西是公平的。没错，关键就在于此。起初他们什么也没做。是国际奥委会（IOC）不得不介入并发布裁决，因为2008年夏季奥运会即将来临。照当时的情况来看，只有获得Speedo赞助的游泳运动员才能穿这件泳衣。所以如果你穿的是Mizuno（美津浓）或其他什么牌子，你立刻就处于劣势了。是的，因为这东西在奥运会之前就已经有了很高的热度。因此国际奥委会裁定，只有当这件泳衣向所有参赛者开放购买时，它才是被允许的。所以事情就是这样。不管有没有赞助，这件泳衣向所有人开放了。
And the 2008 Olympics came and records were made at an unbelievable rate. Yeah. So this was the year that Michael Phelps won like eight gold medals. Yeah. And he did it in the Speedo Laser Racer. And he wasn't the only one breaking records. At the 2008 Olympics, there were 25 world records broken. And of the swimmers who meddled, more than 90% of them were wearing this suit.
接着2008年奥运会开幕了，各项纪录以令人难以置信的速度被打破。是的。所以这一年迈克尔·菲尔普斯赢得了大约八枚金牌。是的。而且他就是穿着Speedo的“鲨鱼皮”完成的。他并不是唯一一个打破纪录的人。在2008年奥运会上，有25项世界纪录被打破。而在获得奖牌的游泳运动员中，超过90%的人都穿着这件泳衣。
I mean, I remember that being a very exciting year for swimming, but did people suspect that the suit was causing too much of an advantage? Like, was the suit banned after that? It started to raise some flags for sure. But what happened next is that other companies caught on to the idea that, like, hey, adding polyurethane to these suits, it kind of works. So they decided, okay, we're going to take it up a notch. And they said, we're going to do it to the whole damn thing. So I've got this picture for you of this so-called rubberized swimsuit. And you let me know if you'd wear that, Roman.
我的意思是，我记得那是游泳运动非常令人兴奋的一年，但人们是否怀疑这件泳衣带来了太大的优势？比如，这件泳衣在那之后被禁了吗？这确实开始引起一些警觉了。但接下来发生的事情是，其他公司也意识到这样一个观念，那就是，嘿，在这些泳衣里添加聚氨酯，这招挺管用的。于是他们决定，好吧，我们要更上一层楼。他们说，我们要把整个该死的泳衣都加上这玩意儿。所以我这里有一张这张所谓的橡胶化泳衣的照片给你看，罗曼，你来看看你愿不愿意穿它。
I mean, I probably could because it's like compression. So like it would like suck in your gut. Like it looks like they've poured this man into this suit. Yeah, I don't know how you get into something like this. Like really, really suck it in and just pray. But anyways, a lot of companies caught on to this and they did their full body version of the suit. And during the 2009 World Aquatic Championships, another 43 records were broken. And in 2009 alone, 147 records were broken.
我的意思是，我大概能穿，因为它就像是压缩衣。所以它会把你的肚子收进去。看起来就像是硬把这个男人塞进了这件泳衣里。是的，我不知道你是怎么穿进这种东西里的。只能真正地、用力地收腹，然后祈祷了。但无论如何，许多公司都意识到了这一点，并推出了他们自己的全身版泳衣。在2009年世界游泳锦标赛期间，又有43项纪录被打破。仅在2009年一年，就有147项纪录被打破。
Well, that's too many records at this point. That's a problem. Yeah, that's when World Aquatics finally decided that enough is enough, and they ultimately banned the suit. But just to play devil's advocate here, which is a term I only learned the origin of when I talked to Jason for his many stories this year, you know, these suits, you know, if they become ubiquitous, wouldn't that just sort of even the playing field again? Like, you know, if everyone's wearing them, then the sort of differential advantage is gone.
好吧，到这个地步纪录就太多了。这成了一个问题。是的，这就是国际泳联终于决定忍无可忍、并最终禁止了这款泳衣的时候。不过，为了扮演魔鬼代言人——这也是我今年在听杰森讲他的迷你故事时才知道出处的一个词，你知道的，这些泳衣，如果它们变得无处不在，难道不会让竞争环境重新变得公平吗？比如，你知道的，如果每个人都穿着它们，那么那种差异带来的优势不就消失了吗？
100%. And there are people in the world of swimming who feel that way. this band was too strict. It was maybe a bit of an overcorrection. But I think there was something about all those records falling so quickly that really freaked people out. It was like progress is good, but like too much of it is really jarring. Yeah, I get that. I get that. And I have another tiny story here for you, Roman, about another controversial sports item. And this one will be more relevant when the Winter Olympics start in a few weeks. So let's talk about curling. I always want to talk about curling. Let's talk about curling. Yeah. So I'll start.
百分之百。游泳界里确实有人有这种感觉。这个禁令太严格了。它可能有点矫枉过正了。但我觉得所有这些纪录以如此之快的速度被打破，确实把人们吓坏了。这就好比进步是件好事，但进步太大就真的让人吃不消了。是的，我懂。我懂。我这里还有另一个小故事给你，罗曼，关于另一个备受争议的体育用品。当几周后冬奥会开幕时，这个话题会更具现实意义。所以我们来聊聊冰壶吧。我一直都想聊冰壶。我们来聊聊冰壶吧。好的。所以我要先声明一下。
out by saying up front that I'm no curling expert. So if you are, please bear with me. But from my understanding, the brooms are used to sweep away debris and clear the path for the stone. Okay? And often, you'd have two sweepers working to get the stone to where it needs to go. But in 2015, new broomheads completely changed the way that the game was being played. It all centers around high-tech fabrics used in curling brooms. It's believed certain broomheads manipulate the rock's path, speed, and even change or stop its direction. These could be performance-enhancing brooms. Yes, that's very possible.
我是个冰壶外行。所以如果你是专家，请多包涵。但据我所知，冰刷是用来扫除碎屑、为冰壶清理出前进路径的。对吧？通常情况下，会有两名刷冰员协作将冰壶送到它需要去的地方。但在2015年，新型冰刷头彻底改变了这项运动的比赛方式。这一切都围绕着冰壶刷中使用的某种高科技面料。据信，某些刷头能够操纵冰壶的路线、速度，甚至改变或停止它的运动方向。这些可能是能提升表现的冰刷。是的，这非常有可能。
Performance-enhancing brooms. I love it. Yeah. So these new heads, they kind of worked like microscopic sandpaper. And so the sweeper was able to more effectively control where the stone was going. And as a result, they didn't really need two sweepers like there had been before. And there was some outrage in the curling world, which led to the so-called sweeping summit in 2016, where they decided that this new broomhead was not going to fly.
能提升表现的冰刷。我太喜欢了。是的。所以这些新刷头的作用有点像微型砂纸。因此，刷冰员能够更有效地控制冰壶的走向。正因如此，他们实际上不再像以前那样需要两名刷冰员了。冰壶界因此出现了一些愤怒的情绪，这导致了2016年所谓的“刷冰峰会”，在会上他们决定这种新刷头行不通。
I love the idea of sweeping summit. That's incredible. I love it. And actually, Roman, in these Olympics, 2026, we almost had another broom controversy. But thankfully, earlier this year, the curling world got out ahead of this one and banned a new set of brushheads. So the Olympics should be an equal playing ground with no huge equipment advantage from one team over another. Thankfully, because I really like to watch curling, just pure. Absolutely. A curly purist. Exactly.
我太喜欢“刷冰峰会”这个概念了。这太不可思议了。我爱死它了。事实上，罗曼，在这次2026年奥运会上，我们差点又引发了一场冰壶争议。但谢天谢地，今年早些时候，冰壶界提前做出了应对，禁止了一套新的刷头。所以这次奥运会应该是一个公平的竞技场，不会出现某个团队对另一个团队有巨大装备优势的情况。谢天谢地，因为我真的很喜欢看纯粹的冰壶比赛。绝对的。一个冰壶纯粹主义者。没。
Thank you, Jake. This is fascinating stuff. I appreciate it. Thanks, Roman. Okay, next up on our Zoom is producer Joe Rosenberg. Joe, what do you have for me? So, Roman, you will recall that I did a story about the Titanic last year, the ship, not the movie. And this mini story is kind of a fun offshoot of that.
谢谢你，杰克。这些太迷人了。我很感激。谢谢你，罗曼。好的，我们Zoom会议上的下一位是制作人乔·罗森伯格。乔，你给我准备了什么？那么，罗曼，你一定还记得去年我讲过一个关于泰坦尼克号的故事，是那艘船，而不是那部电影。而这个迷你故事算是那个故事的一个有趣衍生。
Okay. So this is like the Titanic coda that never was. Yeah. Although, to be clear, no one needs to go back and listen to the Titanic episode to follow this story. But they should because it's a really good episode. It's a fun one. Oh, yeah. No.
好的。所以这就好比从未问世过的泰坦尼克号尾声。是的。尽管需要澄清的是，没有人需要回头去听泰坦尼克号那一集就能听懂这个故事。但他们应该去听，因为那真的是很好的一集。那期很有趣。哦，对。没错。
I mean, hey, definitely. It's the Titanic. Everyone loves the Titanic. And just a quick side note that I actually have like 10 Titanic option stories. Because I found that if a story even just contains the word Titanic, Suddenly, magically, everyone is like, fascinating. You know, like, the pets of the Titanic. But really, I wanted to tell this particular side story
我的意思是，嘿，绝对的。那是泰坦尼克号。每个人都爱泰坦尼克号。顺便提一下，我实际上大概有10个关于泰坦尼克号的备选故事。因为我发现，如果一个故事里哪怕仅仅包含“泰坦尼克号”这个词，突然之间，神奇地，每个人都会说：太迷人了。你知道的，比如泰坦尼克号上的宠物。但实际上，我想讲这个特定的支线故事。
because the Titanic episode never really had, like, characters we follow on a journey. It was very technical. So today, I wanted to correct for that by telling the tale of a single remarkable person named Violet Constance Jessup. Okay. And Violet Jessup's biography has the two things you want in a good story,
因为泰坦尼克号那一集并没有真正那种我们跟随其经历去了解的角色。它非常技术性。所以今天，我想通过讲述一个名叫维奥莱特·康斯坦丝·杰瑟普（Violet Constance Jessup）的杰出女性的故事来弥补这一点。好的。而维奥莱特·杰瑟普的生平具备了你在一个好故事中想要的两样东西。
which is a great fact pattern, and it culminates in an incredible climactic action set piece. Okay. Because her life is like, it's like Groundhog Day meets Titanic. Well, that sounds very ominous because I know what happens on the Titanic, so please continue. Yeah, it is, it's crazy. And yes, scary things will be happening momentarily. So set the stage from me here. Who is Violet Constance Jessup, other than a woman with an incredible name?
也就是极佳的事实设定，并且它以一个令人难以置信的、高潮迭起的大动作场景告终。好吧。因为她的人生就像是，就像是《土拨鼠之日》遇上泰坦尼克号。嗯，听起来很不祥，因为我知道泰坦尼克号上发生了什么，所以请继续。是的，太疯狂了。是的，可怕的事情马上就要发生了。所以先为我铺垫一下。维奥莱特·康斯坦丝·杰瑟普是谁，除了她拥有一个不可思议的名字之外？
So Violet Jessup is born in 1887 in Argentina to Irish immigrant sheep farmers. She is the oldest of six children. And as a young woman, she dreams of becoming a nurse. But then before she can chase that dream, her father dies and her mother gets sick, meaning very early on, Violet has to become the family breadwinner. And so, despite a lifelong fear of drowning and the fact that she has never learned to swim. And this fact won't come into play later at all. Okay, go ahead.
所以维奥莱特·杰瑟普于1887年出生于阿根廷，父母是爱尔兰移民牧羊人。她是六个孩子中的老大。作为一个年轻女性，她梦想成为一名护士。但就在她追求这个梦想之前，她的父亲去世了，母亲也生病了，这意味着维奥莱特很早就不得不成为家里的顶梁柱。因此，尽管她终身恐水，而且从来没学会游泳。而这个事实后来完全不会发挥任何作用。好吧，你继续。
Not at all, not one bit. Violet signs up to work as a stewardess on passenger ships. And she eventually ends up working as a stewardess specifically for the White Star Line shipping company. And sure enough, in 1911, Violet is assigned to be a stewardess on the maiden voyage of the White Star Line's newest ocean liner, the largest ship in the world, designed by famous ship designer Thomas Andrews, sailing under the command. of Captain Edward Smith and described in the press as practically unsinkable. The RMS Olympic.
完全不会，一点也不会。维奥莱特报名在客轮上当乘务员（女服务员）。她最终成了一名专门为白星航运公司（White Star Line）工作的乘务员。果不其然，在1911年，维奥莱特被指派在白星航运公司最新远洋客轮的处女航上担任乘务员，这是世界上最大的船，由著名船舶设计师托马斯·安德鲁斯设计，在船长爱德华·史密斯的指挥下航行，被媒体誉为“永不沉没”的船。RMS奥林匹克号。
Oh, not the Titanic. Titanic hadn't been built yet, you know, or it was being built. And, you know, in reality, in this period in the 1900s, these shipping companies are coming out with larger and larger ships,
哦，不是泰坦尼克号。泰坦尼克号还没建造呢，你知道的，或者说正在建造中。而且，说实话，在20世纪这一时期，这些航运公司不断推出越来越大的船。
like every five seconds. And so at this moment in 1911, the quote-unquote largest ship ever built is the Olympic. And tell me if this sounds familiar because on one fateful trip, In September of 1911, on a transatlantic voyage from Southampton to New York, a giant crash and shutter runs through the length of the ship.
就像每隔五秒钟就会推出一艘。所以在1911年这个时刻，所谓“有史以来建造的最大船只”就是奥林匹克号。你听听这听起来是不是很熟悉，因为在某次命中注定的航行中，在1911年9月，在从南安普顿到纽约的跨大西洋航行中，一声巨大的撞击和震颤贯穿了整艘船。
Because the Olympics steel-plated haul had been severely punctured on its starboard side below the waterline. I mean, that sounds very fire. Yeah. And what had happened was that the Olympic had actually collided with another ship, a British naval cruiser. And the damage to the Olympic was actually very serious. but thankfully only two of her watertight compartments flooded, the rest stay dry, and the Olympic stays afloat and very luckily no one is killed. And so what did Violet Jessup make of this near-death experience or whatever it was?
因为奥林匹克号钢板铺就的船体在水线以下的右舷侧被严重撞穿。我的意思是，听起来非常严重。是的。当时发生的事情是，奥林匹克号实际上与另一艘船相撞了，是一艘英国皇家海军巡洋舰。奥林匹克号受到的损伤其实非常严重，但谢天谢地，它的水密舱只有两个进水了，其余的保持干燥，奥林匹克号得以浮在水面上，非常幸运的是没有人丧生。那么，维奥莱特·杰瑟普对这次近乎死亡的经历或者不管它是什么经历作何感想呢？
Right, yeah. We don't know her thoughts at this early stage of this story, but it's probably something like, man, to think I was a stewardess during a gigantic collision on a transatlantic voyage of the largest ship in the world. What a once-in-a-lifetime experience. But then, I think you see where this is going. Fast-forward seven months to April of 1912, when Violet is again picked to be
对，没错。在这个故事的早期阶段我们不知道她的想法，但大概是这种感觉：天哪，真没想到我在一艘世界上最大的船进行跨大西洋航行发生巨大碰撞时竟然是个乘务员。这是多么千载难逢的经历啊。但随后，我想你看出这是要往哪里发展了。快进七个月到1912年4月，当时维奥莱特再次被选中。
on the maiden voyage of the White Star Line's newest ship, the largest ship in the world, designed by famous ship designer, Thomas Andrews, sailing under the command of Captain Edward Smith, and described in the press as practically unsinkable, the new sister ship of the Olympic, the RMS. Titanic.
登上白星航运公司最新船舶的处女航，这是世界上最大的船，由著名船舶设计师托马斯·安德鲁斯设计，在船长爱德华·史密斯的指挥下航行，并在媒体上被描述为实际上永不沉没，也就是奥林匹克号的新姊妹船——RMS泰坦尼克号。
Wow. And the Titanic is actually basically identical to the Olympic, just a tiny bit bigger. And on the Titanic's inaugural transatlantic voyage from South Hampton to New York,
哇。而泰坦尼克号实际上和奥林匹克号基本上一模一样，只是稍微大了一点点。在泰坦尼克号从南安普顿到纽约的首航期间。
as Violet is in her cabin, getting ready for bed, and has finished reciting a prayer to protect the ship from fire and water. A giant crash and shutter runs through the entire length of the ship because its steel-plated hall
当维奥莱特在她的船舱里准备睡觉、刚刚念完一段祈祷船只免受水火之灾的祷告时。一声巨大的撞击和震颤贯穿了整艘船，因为它的钢板船体。
had been severely punctured on its starboard side just below the water line. Only this time it's an iceberg. At least there's a little bit of difference there. But I am seeing a familiar pattern playing out. Yeah. And ironically, one of the reasons so many people on the Titanic thought she was going to be fine and delayed getting onto lifeboats was because the Olympic hadn't sunk, right?
在水线下方刚好的右舷侧被严重撞穿。只不过这一次是一座冰山。至少这里还有一点点不同。但我确实看到了一个熟悉的剧本在上演。是的。而且讽刺的是，泰坦尼克号上之所以有那么多人认为她会安然无恙并延迟登上救生艇，原因之一就是奥林匹克号当时并没有沉没，对吧？
Right. And so they thought the Titanic wouldn't sink either. That makes sense. I mean, like the Olympic had survived this collision and with a gash along the starboard side. So, you know, could an iceberg be anywhere? worse? Right, exactly. It sounds less bad, if anything, right? Yeah. But of course, the Titanic does, in fact, sink. And this time, a bunch of white star officers and officials who had been on the Olympic in that first crash are also on the Titanic. And this time they do not survive. They
没错。所以他们以为泰坦尼克号也不会沉。这说得通。我的意思是，奥林匹克号在右舷侧有一道大裂口的情况下依然在碰撞中幸存了下来。所以，一座冰山能有多糟糕呢？对，没错。怎么听都觉得没那么糟糕，对吧？对。但当然，泰坦尼克号事实上确实沉没了。而这一次，一帮曾在第一次碰撞中登上过奥林匹克号的白星航运公司官员和高管也在泰坦尼克号上。而这一次他们没有幸存下来。他们。
all go down with the ship. But I hope Violet Jessup survives, right? She does. She does. She actually initially stays in her cabin, but as Stewart comes down and convinces her the ship is really sinking, And Violet gets out of there. She gets on a lifeboat. And so by the skin of her teeth, Violet Jessup lives. At which point, she is like, to think I survive the collisions of the Olympic and the Titanic. Sister ships.
全都随船沉入了海底。但我希望维奥莱特·杰位数能幸存，对吧？她活下来了。她确实活下来了。她最初其实待在自己的船舱里，但随着一名乘务员走下来并说服她船真的在下沉，维奥莱特便离开了那里。她登上了救生艇。就这样，千钧一发之际，维奥莱特·杰瑟普活了下来。此时此刻，她的想法大概是：真不敢相信我经历了奥林匹克号和泰坦尼克号的碰撞。姊妹船。
Sister ships. Surely life cannot get any crazier than this. But then, in 1914. Oh, you were kidding me, Joe. I'm not kidding you. World War I breaks out. And Violet fulfills her lifelong dream to train as a nurse with the Red Cross.
姊妹船。生活肯定不会比这更疯狂了吧。然而到了1914年。哦，你在逗我吧，乔。我没逗你。第一次世界大战爆发了。维奥莱特实现了她终生的梦想，在红十字会接受培训成为一名护士。
which is the good news. The bad news is that she gets assigned as a medical stewardess on a white star line passenger liner which has been converted for the war effort into the newest, largest hospital ship in the world. And the name of that ship is the HMHS Britannic,
这是好消息。坏消息是，她被指派到白星航运公司的一艘客轮上担任医疗乘务员，这艘客轮为了战争需要已被改造成最新、世界上最大的医院船。那艘船的名字叫HMHS不列颠号（HMHS Britannic）。
which is none other than the third and final sister ship of the Olympic and the Titanic. This is crazy. I promised you Groundhog Day meets Titanic, and I deliver Groundhog Day meets Titanic. And once again, basically the exact same ship, just a little bigger, but like really the same. And this time, Britannic is declared to be even safer than the Titanic, because after the Titanic sank, they gave the Britannic a full double-layered haul. But of course, there's just one problem.
它正是奥林匹克号和泰坦尼克号的第三艘也是最后一艘姊妹船。这太疯狂了。我向你保证过《土拨鼠之日》遇上泰坦尼克号，我真的兑现了《土拨鼠之日》遇上泰坦尼克号。而且基本上又是完全一样的船，只是稍微大了一点，但真的就是同一艘船。这一次，不列颠号被宣称甚至比泰坦尼克号更安全，因为在泰坦尼克号沉没后，他们给不列颠号配备了完整的双层船体。但当然，这里有一个问题。
Do you want to guess what that is? Well, Violet Jessup is on board for one thing. Violet Jessup is on board. Violet Jessup has entered the chat. Which is how it comes to pass, and I hate to say it. One morning in November of 1916, on a voyage from Southampton to Greece, a giant crash and shutter runs through the length of the ship because its steel-plated hall had been severely punctured on its starboard side below the waterline. Okay, well, here we go. So what was it this time that they crashed into or whatever?
你想猜猜那是什么吗？好吧，维奥莱特·杰瑟普在船上，这是一个原因。维奥莱特·杰瑟普在船上。维奥莱特·杰瑟普加入了群聊。事情就是这样发生的，而我实在不想这么说。1916年11月的一个早晨，在从南安普顿开往希腊的航行中，一声巨大的撞击和震颤贯穿了整艘船，因为其钢板船体在水线以下的右舷侧被严重撞穿。好吧，那么我们又来了。所以这一次他们撞到了什么东西或者别的什么？
Well, this time they had crashed into nothing this time, well, or they did in a sense because the Britannic had struck a mine, a German mine. And Roman, I promised you a big climactic action set piece, and here it is, because we actually have some tape of an interview Violet herself gave many years later describing what happened. I was upstairs in the pantry, getting this nurse at breakfast, and all the staff, medical staff, dozens of doctors, you see, and nurses. They were all in the saloon at breakfast. Right.
好吧，这一次他们什么也没有撞到，或者说从某种意义上讲他们确实撞了，因为不列颠号撞上了一枚水雷，一枚德国水雷。罗曼，我向你保证过有一个高潮迭起的大动作场景，它来了，因为我们确实保留了一些多年后维奥莱特本人接受采访的录音，描述了当时发生的事情。我当时在楼上的餐具室里，正准备把早餐给一位护士送去，所有的工作人员，医务人员，几十名医生，你看，还有护士。他们当时都在沙龙里吃早餐。没错。
When, sudden, they crash. Right. Well, no sooner does that crash happen that everybody stood off from their table and disappeared. And it was so different to the Titanic where there didn't seem to be any panicky movement, you know. So famously on the Titanic, everyone had been, you know, kind of very unbothered by the crashing sensation and didn't believe anything was wrong. But this time around, of course, everyone knows what happened to the Titanic. But they're also, like, you know, trained personnel on a medical ship in the middle of the war. And so Violet just races back to the cabin where she had been helping this very sick nurse.
突然间，他们撞船了。好吧，撞击发生后不久，每个人都从桌子旁站起来消失了。这与泰坦尼克号太不一样了，当时似乎没有任何恐慌的举动，你知道的。正如大家所知，在泰坦尼克号上，每个人都对碰撞的感觉非常漠不关心，不相信有什么不对劲。但这一次，当然，每个人都知道泰坦尼克号发生了什么。但他们同时也是战争期间一艘医疗船上受过训练的人员。所以维奥莱特只是冲回了船舱，她刚才一直在那里照顾这位病得很重的护士。
And she helps get both herself and this alien nurse into their coats and then into their life jackets. And they rush toward the lifeboats. But not before Violet goes to grab one highly critical item. After the Titanic, I used to, you know, moan that on the Carpagia, that picked the south, I couldn't buy a toothbrush. And I couldn't live without cleaning my teeth, you see. And I must tell you the joke about the family, why, the next time you go on a boat, for God's sake, if it's going to sing, put your toothbrush in your pocket. So, while the ship is beginning to tilt and Violet is helping get the sick freemate. to the deck
她帮自己和这位生病的护士穿上大衣，然后穿上救生衣。她们向救生艇冲去。但在那之前，维奥莱特去拿了一件至关重要的物品。在泰坦尼克号事件之后，我经常抱怨说，在卡帕西亚号上——那艘救起幸存者的船，我买不到牙刷。没有牙齿清洁我简直无法生活，你看。我必须告诉你关于这个家庭的笑话，维奥莱特，下次你上船的时候，看在上帝的份上，如果它要沉的话，把你的牙刷放进口袋里。所以，当船开始倾斜、维奥莱特正帮着把这位生病的护士送上甲板时。
she's like wait one second I just have to grab my toothbrush that is an amazing detail I love it I love it so much
她心想：等一下，我得去拿我的牙刷。这是一个太棒的细节了，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。
it's it for me it's the high point of the story and at this point although everyone is rushing to the lifeboats no one on the Britannic is sure yet
对我来说，这是这个故事的高潮。而在此时，尽管每个人都在冲向救生艇，但船上没有人能确定。
whether the ship will ultimately sink or not including violent because the ship's only tilting forward a little but and this is
这艘船最终会不会沉没，包括维奥莱特在内，因为船只只向前倾斜了一点点，而这。
just a brutal piece of bad luck during the voyage the patients in the ship's hospital ward had complained about stifling heat so against standing orders the portholes on the side of the ship had been left open
只是航行中极其残酷的一件倒霉事：船上医院病房的病人们抱怨闷热难耐，所以违反了标准规定，船侧的舷窗被留着敞开。
and so after the explosion even though only four compartments are flooded Britannic tilts forward just enough that more water from the ocean begins flowing through the open portholes and into the rest of the ship I mean her bad luck
因此在爆炸发生后，尽管只有四个舱室进水，不列颠号还是向前倾斜了一点，足以让更多的海水通过敞开的舷窗涌入船舱的其他部分。我的意思是，她的倒霉运气。
truly cannot be stopped at this point no it's brutal So while Violet is grabbing her toothbrush, the ship is beginning to sink faster and faster. But eventually she gets herself and her charge onto the deck and into the lifeboats. And almost everyone is now in the boats at this point, and they're still on the deck waiting for the orders to lower. But as the ship's angle gets worse, the officers in charge of two of the lifeboats panic and decide to lower their lifeboats just as soon. as they're full, right away before any order is given. And one of those boats that lowers too early contains Violet Jessin.
到了这个时候真的是挡也挡不住。不，这太惨了。所以当维奥莱特在拿她的牙刷时，船开始越沉越快。但最终她带着她照顾的人来到了甲板上并上了救生艇。此时几乎所有人都已经在救生艇上了，他们仍然在甲板上等待下放的命令。但随着船倾斜的角度越来越大，负责其中两艘救生艇的军官慌了手脚，决定一等救生艇坐满就立刻把它们放下，不等任何命令下达。其中一艘过早放下的救生艇上就坐着维奥莱特·杰瑟普。
And as we touched Warhouse, everybody's done so. Out of the boat. Out of the boat? I said, why I was doing that? And so Violet, perplexed, looks around to see what it was that everyone else was looking at that made them jump out of the boat. And what's happening is that the ship's gigantic, bronze propellers are half out of the water, and they are still going at full steam,
正如我们所接触到的那样，每个人都这么做了。跳出船。跳出船？我说，我当时为什么要这么做？所以维奥莱特感到困惑，环顾四周，想看看其他人到底在看什么，以至于让他们从船上跳了下去。原来发生的情况是，这艘船巨大的青铜螺旋桨有一半露在水面上，而且它们仍然在全速运转，
and they are sucking the two lifeboats towards them, and they are just chopping the lifeboats and everything in their path into bits. So Violet is like, oh, shit. Well, I was left alone, you see, and I decided, which would it be better to be? Cut the pieces or drown. I mean, I had to make the decision. So Violet has this choice, you know, get cut to pieces or drown. And so Violet says, you know what, I'll take my chances with drowning, and she jumps over the side.
它们正在把两艘救生艇向自己方向吸过去，并且正在把救生艇以及它们路径上的一切东西都切成碎块。所以维奥莱特心想：哦，操。好吧，你看，只剩下我一个人了，我决定，究竟哪种情况更好一点？被切成碎块还是淹死。我的意思是，我必须做个决定。所以维奥莱特面临着这样的选择：要么被切成碎块，要么被淹死。于是维奥莱特说，管他的，我宁愿去赌一把能不能在溺水中活下来，然后她跳了下去。
But I would assume that's okay, but, you know, that she doesn't swim because, like, she must have a life jacket on, right? You would think, but it's at this point that Violet realizes she has made a rookie mistake. I had this lovely coat. Well, instead of putting the coat over the lifestyle, I put the life belt over the coat. And it killed the passage if they did that. And so when I went into the water, I went down miles with the weight of, you know, closed, and came up under the boat. And I got a terrible blow on the head. And, you know, it did occur to me.
但我想这应该没问题，不过，你知道的，她不会游泳，因为，她身上肯定穿着救生衣吧？你可能会这么想，但正是在这个时候，维奥莱特意识到自己犯了一个菜鸟错误。我当时穿着这件漂亮的大衣。好吧，我没有把大衣穿在救生衣外面，而是把救生圈套在了大衣外面。人们这样做的话会丢掉性命的。所以当我跳进水里时，我带着沉重的衣服下沉了无数英里，然后从船底下钻了上来。我的头部受到了可怕的撞击。而且，你知道的，我确实闪过一个念头。
If I get another like that, I'll be finished. Oh, my God. This is terrifying. So she's, like, stuck underwater underneath the boat. She is stuck underwater underneath the boat. and she is still heading along with the boat toward the spinning propellers. And she's incredibly disoriented
如果我再挨上这么一下，我就完蛋了。哦天哪。这太可怕了。所以她，像是被困在船底下的水里。她被困在船底下的水里。而且她正跟着船一起朝旋转的螺旋桨冲过去。她极度迷失方向。
and she describes the noise as just being like beyond anything she'd ever heard. But she kicks her way clear of the bottom of the boat and clear of the suction of the propeller just as the lifeboat gets chopped to pieces. Amazing. That's so incredible. Finally, she reaches the surface, still waterlogged in her coat
她形容那声音简直超越了她听过的任何声音。但她拼命踢水，在救生艇被粉碎的瞬间，终于脱离了船底和螺旋桨的吸力范围。太棒了。这太不可思议了。最终她浮出了水面，身上穿着沉重吸水的衣服。
with her nose just like barely out of the water. until she sees another life jacket float by, and she grabs it and manages to steady herself. So while she's clinging on to this life jacket in the water, Violet watches again as this time the Britannic, the third and final sister ship of the Olympic and Titanic, itself sinks faster and faster into the water. And in some ways, this round is the most terrifying,
她的鼻子刚刚好露出水面，直到她看到另一个救生衣漂过，她一把抓住它，设法稳住了自己。所以当她在水里紧紧抓着这件救生衣时，维奥莱特眼睁睁地看着这一次，不列颠号——奥林匹克号和泰坦尼克号的第三艘也是最后一艘姊妹船，自身在水中越沉越快。在某种程度上，这一轮是最可怕的。
because the Britannic is sinking in much shallower seas, than the Titanic had been. So in this case, the ship is actually longer than the ocean is deep. So the ship's stern is still sticking out of the water when its bow smashes into the ocean floor.
因为不列颠号沉没的水域比当年泰坦尼克号要浅得多。所以在这种情况下，船的身长实际上比海洋的深度还要长。所以当船首撞击到海底时，船尾仍然高高地戳在水面上。
And Violet watches as the whole ship just jutters and groans. And writing about it later, she said, quote, all the deck machinery fell into the sea like a child's toys. Then she took a fearful plunge her stern rearing hundreds of feet into the air, until with a final roar, she disappeared into the depths, the noise of her going, resounding through the water with an undreamt of violence.
维奥莱特看着整艘船剧烈震颤并发出呻吟。她后来在记述中写道：“所有的甲板机械都像小孩子的玩具一样落入海中。”接着，她做出了一个可怕的下坠，船尾高高翘起数百英尺直插云霄，伴随着一声最后的轰鸣，她消失在深渊之中，其离去的声音在水中回荡，带着一种超乎想象的暴力感。
That's incredible. So for all those people who were waiting on other lifeboats and people that were still on the ship, like did they get off the ship when this happened, when it hit the ocean floor? Yes. Yes. So very, very fortunately, before the ship sank, the captain had ordered the propellers to stop. so the other lifeboats could get away. And because the ship had only been on its way to pick up wounded, there's actually very few patients on the boat.
这太不可思议了。所以对于所有那些在其他救生艇上等待的人以及仍然在船上的人来说，当发生这种情况、当船撞击海底时，他们有离开那艘船吗？是的。是的。所以非常、非常幸运的是，在船沉没之前，船长下令停止螺旋桨运转。这样其他救生艇就能逃离了。而且因为这艘船当时只是在去接伤员的路上，船上的病人其实非常少。
Oh. So 30 people die, but it could have been far worse. And most of those who died were the ones in those two boats that Violet had been on. And so once again, Violet Jessup is really lucky. Yeah. Well, it depends on how you look at it. We're also very, very unlucky. No, yes, exactly.
哦。所以有30人丧生，但本来可能会更糟。而大多数死者都是维奥莱特坐过的那两艘救生艇上的人。所以再一次，维奥莱特·杰瑟普真的是太幸运了。是的。嗯，这取决于你如何看待它。我们也可以说她非常、非常倒霉。不，是的，没错。
I like your way better. Thank you. But, and, you know, some good luck continues because she eventually is picked up by another boat and pulled the safety. And when she gets to shore, she does, in fact, brush her teeth with her toothbrush,
我更喜欢你的那种说法。谢谢。但是，你知道的，好运还在继续，她最终被另一艘船救起并拉上岸。当她到达岸边时，她事实上真的用牙刷刷了牙。
which apparently never left her side. And that's how Violet Jessup manages to survive the three disasters of the White Star Line's three sister ships, the Olympic, the Titanic, and the Britannic. And after that,
这把牙刷显然从未离开过她的身边。就这样，维奥莱特·杰瑟普设法在白星航运公司三艘姊妹船——奥林匹克号、泰坦尼克号和不列颠号的三场灾难中全部生还。在这之后。
she went on to write a beautifully written memoir only to be published after her death under the title, Titanic Survivor. Well, that's only like the half of it, or the third of it, actually. Like, Titanic Survivor is really underselling the whole story. Yeah, I mean, it is quite possibly the most under-informative title of all time. But I also just have to say, as a final note, Violet Jessup is not the only person this happened to surviving all three of these ships. She's kind of the glamorous one, but there was one other guy. His name was Arthur Priest.
她写了一本文字优美的回忆录，并在她去世后以《泰坦尼克号幸存者》为书名出版。好吧，那只说了一半，或者说实际上只说了一三。就像是，《泰坦尼克号幸存者》真的严重低估了整个故事。是的，我的意思是，这很可能是史上信息量最低的书名。但作为最后的备注，我必须说，维奥莱特·杰瑟普并不是经历过这三艘船并全部幸存的唯一一个人。她算是其中光鲜亮丽的那一个，但还有另外一个人。他的名字叫阿瑟·普里斯特（Arthur Priest）。
He was a boiler room stoker for the White Star Lines. And we don't know much about him, but he actually outdoes even Violet because he survived. Get this. Four ship sinkings and two major collisions. Another one of these people where you can't tell if they're the luckiest person around you or the unluckiest person in the world. Exactly. Like is their glass of luck half empty or half full? We'll never know.
他是白星航运公司的锅炉房司炉工。我们对他的了解不多，但他甚至比维奥莱特还要厉害，因为他活了下来。你听着。经历过四次沉船和两次重大碰撞。又是那种让你分不清他究竟是周围最幸运的人还是世上最倒霉的人的人。没错。就像他们的幸运杯到底是半空还是半满？我们永远不会知道了。
But I think the lesson of Violet Jessup is like, you know, you don't know if your next ship is going to sink. The best you can do is just grab your toothbrush and just keep your head above water. Yeah, I think that's right. I mean, like even if you don't know how to swim. She didn't know how to swim, Joe. It had to do, like, she had tuberculosis when she was young. There was a lung thing. It's not her fault.
但我觉得维奥莱特·杰瑟普给我们的教训是：你永远不知道你的下一艘船会不会沉没。你能做的最好的事情就是抓紧你的牙刷，然后让你的头部保持在水面之上。是的，我觉得这很有道理。我的意思是，即使你不会游泳。她不会游泳，乔。这有关系，她年轻时患过结核病。那是肺部的问题。这又不是她的错。
Well, that's amazing. What a great story show. I really appreciate it. This is fun. Thank you so much, Roman. Stay tuned. We have one more mini story after the break. We are back, and last but not least, it's our digital director and 99% Invisible City co-author, Kurt Kohlstead.
好吧，这太惊人了。多棒的故事啊，乔。我真的很感激。这太有趣了。非常感谢你，罗曼。请继续收听。休息过后我们还有一个迷你故事。我们回来了，压轴出场的是我们的数字总监兼《99%无形》城市合著者库尔特·科尔斯特德。
Hey, Kurt. Hey, Roman. You know, I remember when we started doing minis, and my, like, small contribution was calling them, like, minis volume one and volume two and volume three. Because you get it, like, volume, like, audience. but also addition, and I just thought that was so clever. Anyway, I'm here to talk about a type of machine called an art-o-mat, as in an automat, but with art. I've got a picture of it here. Okay, so it's like a big, glitzy box.
嘿，库尔特。嘿，罗曼。你知道的，我记得当我们开始做迷你故事时，我那微不足道的贡献就是把它们叫做，比如迷你故事第一卷、第二卷和第三卷。因为你懂的，卷（Volume），就像音量或受众的意思。但也代表版本（edition），我当时觉得这太机智了。不管怎样，我来这里是想谈谈一种叫做Art-o-mat的机器，就像自动售货机（Automat），但卖的是艺术品。我这里有一张它的照片。好的，所以它看起来像一个巨大、闪亮的盒子。
It kind of looks like a cigarette dispenser, like an old-time cigarette dispenser, but a little fancier and nicer. You're exactly right. If you look closely, you can see that there are these 10 telltale columns for, you know, 10 different brands of cigarette. But in the converted artomat, each column corresponds to a different artist. So you insert $5, you pick a column, you pull this lever, you see the stack shift, and you hear this like big thunk as the thing that you want, like lands in the dispenser. It's just very gratifying as like a tactile experience. That's so cool.
它有点像卷烟售货机，那种老式的香烟售货机，但更花哨、更精致一些。完全正确。如果你仔细看，你会发现有10个标志性的列，分别对应（你知道的）10个不同的香烟品牌。但在改造后的Art-o-mat中，每一列都对应着不同的艺术家。你投入5美元，选一个列，拉动这个杠杆，你会看到货栈移位，并且当你想要的东西“砰”的一声落入取货口时，你会听到一声巨响。作为一种触觉体验，这非常令人满足。太酷了。
So tell me about these packs of art. What is contained in a pack of art? Well, so I have one of these. art. That's at my local cat cafe. And I went there and I picked up a funky whole punch flip book, a painting of a chicken, and a woodblock flower print. And those may all seem like very different kinds of art, but they all have one thing in common, their size. Because each artwork has to fit in this very specific set of dimensions. And we're talking precisely three and a quarter inches long by two and an eighth inches wide by six. seven-eighths of an inch thick. Very specific. I mean, but, you know, cigarette packs aren't the exact same size. You can get, like, filterless cigarettes that are smaller.
所以跟我讲讲这些艺术包。艺术包里都装了些什么？好吧，所以我手头就有一个这种艺术包。来自我当地的一家猫咖。我去那里拿到了一个时髦的打孔翻页书、一幅画着小鸡的画作以及一张木刻花卉版画。这些看起来可能是非常不同种类的艺术品，但它们都有一个共同点，那就是它们的尺寸。因为每一件艺术品都必须符合这个非常特定的一组尺寸。我们说的是精确的长3.25英寸、宽2.125英寸、厚0.875英寸。非常具体。我的意思是，但是，你知道的，烟盒并不是完全相同尺寸的。你可以买到那种更小的无过滤嘴香烟。
So why do these have to be the same size? Yeah, there are definitely exceptions, but those dimensions are the most common size. And it's what's called the king-sized hard pack. Oh, yeah. And some of that, like, convergence around that size has to do with legislation. For example, back in the day, they created this minimum per pack of, 20 cigarettes, which sounds kind of weird, right? Like, it is a thing so legislate. But the idea was that it would make it more expensive for like youths to buy cigarettes. And so, you know, you'd get
那为什么这些必须是相同尺寸的呢？是的，肯定有例外，但这些尺寸是最常见的尺寸。这就是所谓的“硬盒长支烟”（king-sized hard pack）。哦，是的。而且围绕这个尺寸的趋同，部分原因与立法有关。例如，在过去，他们规定了每包香烟的最低数量为20支，这听起来有点奇怪，对吧？就像，这是件需要立法的事。但其想法是，这会让年轻人买香烟的成本更高。所以，你知道的，你会看到。
less kids smoking. I get it. And then of course, with the advent and spread of vending machines, cigarette companies wanted to conform. You know, there's this incentive because if all the other brands have packs that fit and yours don't, your brand is going to get left out of this very lucrative sales venue. Yeah, because this is where underage children buy their cigarettes. Yeah, I mean, I remember those being on the outsides
抽烟的少儿变少。我懂。然后当然，随着自动售货机的出现和普及，香烟公司想要顺应潮流。这里有一个激励机制，因为如果所有其他品牌的包装都合适而你的不合适，你的品牌就会被排除在这个非常赚钱的销售渠道之外。是的，因为这就是未成年儿童买烟的地方。是的，我的意思是，我记得那些机器在建筑物的外面。
of buildings and thinking, I could use my lunch money for this. So where did this idea of the Art of Matt come from? Is this just at your cat cafe or is it more widespread? No, it's more widespread. It actually started with this artist named Clark Whittington, who
并且心想，我可以把我的午餐钱用来买这个。所以这个Art-o-mat的创意是从哪里来的？这只是在你常去的猫咖才有，还是说它更普遍？不，它更普遍。它最初是由一个名叫克拉克·威廷顿（Clark Whittington）的艺术家发起的。
back in the 90s, he had this idea to make art more accessible by vending it out of machines, like you would with junk food. And then he moved to Winston-Salem, also known as Camel City, which is the hometown of R.J. Reynolds' tobacco company. So here he is in the heart of big tobacco land, but at a time when there are more and more regulations restricting cigarette vending. As there should be.
在90年代，他萌生了一个想法，即通过售货机来售卖艺术品，就像卖垃圾食品那样，从而让艺术更亲民。然后他搬到了温斯顿-萨勒姆（Winston-Salem），也被称为“骆驼城”，那是雷诺公司（R.J. Reynolds）烟草公司的发源地。所以他来到了烟草大王腹地的中心，但当时正值有越来越多的法规限制香烟自动售货机。本该如此。
Yeah, I mean, yeah, it wasn't like a bad thing. And so Whittington, you know, sought out a disused machine and he converted it to spit out Polaroid prints that he tacked to blocks of wood and made like part of this local art show. And that was the very first artomat. Well, this sounds very cool, very clever. And I'm sort of wondering, though, you know some of our rules on this show when it comes to telling design and clever stories is that this sounds a little bit like a doo-wop. Yes, yes. the old dude with a project. Yeah, yeah, that old trip wire.
是的，我的意思是，这并不是件坏事。所以威廷顿寻找了一台废弃的机器，将其改造吐出宝丽来（Polaroid）照片，他把照片钉在木块上，作为当地艺术展的一部分。这就是最早的Art-o-mat。好吧，这听起来非常酷，非常聪明。不过我有点好奇，你知道我们在节目中关于讲述设计和聪明的隐喻故事的一些规则，这听起来有点像是“搞个项目的直男”（dude with a project）。是的，是的。老兄带着个项目。是的，是的，那个老绊马索。
So for people who don't know, I kind of have a rule about these things we call dude with a project. Because, like, we wanted to cover everyday design that you encounter and that you don't notice. And dude with a project type design stories are often just like, you know, clever, fancy things that people put out in the world. Maybe as a provocation, that's a design provocation. Maybe it's something beautiful or artistic.
所以对于不了解的人来说，我针对这些我们称之为“搞个项目的直男”的事情设立了一条规则。因为，我们想要报道的是你所遇到却没有注意到的日常设计。而“搞个项目的直男”类型的设计故事，往往只是一些人们带到世界上的聪明、花哨的东西。也许作为一种挑衅，那是一种设计挑衅。也许它是某种美丽或艺术化的东西。
But it just was a thing that I felt other design. you know, shops covered well and we didn't need to cover. So why would you want us to cover automats? Yeah, well, I think you are 100% right that that is like definitionally what we're talking about here. Like this started as a dude with a project. Yeah. But these artomats, they've gotten a lot bigger as a project and frankly, a lot more
但这只是我觉得其他设计，你知道，商店报道得很好的东西，而我们不需要报道。所以你为什么想让我们报道 Artomat 呢？是的，好吧，我觉得你百分之百说对了，这正是我们这里从定义上在谈论的事情。比如这最初是一个人的项目。是的。但这些 Artomat，它们作为一个项目已经变得大得多，坦白说，也更有
interesting because that one machine led to another and another and now, Decades later, there are over 200 aromatts around the country, even a few internationally, and they have works by over 400 different artists. So it's a dude with a big project. Yeah, it's a dude and big project. But it's not just that because, you know, for his part, Whittington figured out that he couldn't just do it on his own. So he created this organization to also oversee the artomats because frankly it just like, yeah, it outgrew his ability. to manage. And so today, there's a lot of work by various people that goes into reviewing and collecting these blocks of art, pairing machines with venues, keeping them stocked, keeping them
意思，因为那一台机器带来了另一台，然后又是一台，现在，几十年过去了，全国各地有两00多个 Artomat，甚至还有一些在国际上，它们展出了400多位不同艺术家的作品。所以这是一个拥有大项目的家伙。是的，这是一个家伙和大项目。但这不仅仅是因为，你知道，就他而言，惠廷顿发现他不能独自完成。所以他创建了这个组织来监督 Artomat，因为坦白说，这就像是，是的，超出了他的管理能力。所以今天，有许多不同的人在从事审查和收集这些艺术方块、将机器与场地进行配对、保持它们有库存、保持它们
in working order. And if you think about it, they have this sort of bigger and richer design story about reuse behind them. And you know me. I'm a big sucker for adaptive reuse, whether it be in architecture or vending machines. Well, I'm sold. This sounds like an interesting dude with an interesting project that sort of brings out some of the things you might not notice and add some sort of color around the built world in an interesting way. So if people are interested in the artomat, where can they find out more? Artomat.org. And the site has stuff like a map of these vending machines around the country. It's a really good map. And the people who run the places with these machines are, often really cool to talk to you. And so it just, yeah, it gives you an excuse to go somewhere
处于正常运转状态的工作。如果你想想看，它们背后有一个关于再利用的更大、更丰富的关于设计的的故事。你了解我。我非常喜欢适应性再利用，无论是在建筑还是自动售货机上。好吧，我被说服了。这听起来像是一个有趣的家伙和一个有趣的项目，它以一种有趣的方式衬托出一些你可能不会注意到的事物，并为人工建造的世界增添了一些色彩。所以如果人们对 Artomat 感兴趣，他们可以在哪里了解更多？Artomat.org。网站上有诸如全国各地这些自动售货机的地图等内容。这是一张非常好的地图。经营这些机器场所的人们，通常聊起来也非常酷。所以它只是，是的，它给了你一个去某个地方的借口
and, like, interact with this thing and learn something new and, you know, maybe get a painting of a chicken while you're at it. I'm always into buying art. People that, if you have any money left over at any moment in your life, you should always buy art. And why not buy it from a cigarette machine? Why not? Better than cigarettes. Much better than cigarettes. That's your sure. Thank you, Kurt. You're very welcome, Robin. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Jacob Medina Gleason, Joe Rosenberg, and Kurt Colstead, edited by Jason DeLeon. Mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Rial. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha.
并且，比如，与这个东西互动并学习一些新的东西，你知道，也许顺便买一幅鸡的画。我一直很喜欢买艺术品。人们，如果你在你生命的任何时刻还有剩余的钱，你都应该买艺术品。为什么不从香烟售货机里买呢？为什么不呢？比香烟好。比香烟好得多。这绝对是。谢谢你，库尔特。不客气，罗宾。《99% Invisible》本周由雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森、乔·罗森伯格和库尔特·科尔斯特德制作，由杰森·德莱昂剪辑。由马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里阿尔创作。由格雷厄姆·赫沙进行事实核查。
Special thanks to Jesse Billingham for the recording of Violet Jessup. Kathy 2 is our executive producer, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashemaddon, Kelly Prime, Talon and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server.
特别感谢杰西·比灵汉姆录制了维奥莱特·杰瑟普的音频。凯西·2是我们的执行制片人，德兰尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、埃met·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉谢·马顿、凯利·普莱姆、塔伦和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99% Invisible》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。
There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那里有该链接，以及 99PI 的每一集往期节目，网址是 99PI.org。谢谢。本集目前没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。